i want it
i want the air cut i want the air cut
more than the snyder
i want the air cut give me the air cut
i'm being
serious give me the air cut god damn it
do you see what you're doing to him
hollywood it's gonna happen it
it's gonna happen all right so there's
this twitter account that i follow
called release the air cut recently lisa
erica tweeted we were the largest trend
of twitter for the entire day of july
20th 2020
and david ayer did his no words peace
hands
signed that the emoji i can never find
when i'm trying to do it in text message
okay so what we're going to do today is
we're going to react to this leaked
page from the original suicide squad
script and this is confirmed
david ayer uh so recently there was a
twitter user
named uh anderud
chuck rob i'm racist
fine whatever american i don't know how
to say that all right it's okay
he said did you shoot all of this and
david air did respond yes i did
shot and edited of course you were not
permitted to see it my friend
well how did this guy get to see the
script page i don't know but what's
funny is
from doing research leading into this
because i didn't want to read the page
just yet because i want to do it on
camera i found this
post that he put out all the way back in
march of 2018 and i think it might be
linked to what's going to be here on the
page it says
after joker dropped harley quinn from
the help and crashed
enchantress made a deal with him he was
going to take harley home and be
king of gotham harley stood up to him
and refused to betray her new friends
the squad turned on him and he escaped
so so let's just see what this script is
all about and let's breeze the names
here
all right okay boomerang joker harley
flag
deadshot enchantress all right i'll be
i'll be joker harley
i'm trying to be like how do we dialogue
this and you could be i'll be the white
guys
boomer i'll be and deadshot yeah boomer
and rick flack and then i yeah i'll be
deadshot just to make it problematic
you get to be harley let's be page 118.
enchantress squares off against the
seven ragged
and exhausted interlopers they approach
her high noon
style boomer reacts turns white with
horror
bloody hell i found walla now they all
see her
waller is levitating upside down behind
the enchantress
unconscious and oddly glowing her head
is
wired up with black inky tendrils from
the enchantress
aura okay so wallers oh no so she has
waller kidnapped right then waller's all
sci-fi right now
got it that stops the squad dead in
their tracks then the arming lights on
their necks begin to flash red
what the hell joker steps out holding
waller's
detonator in his hand one more step you
die
because snitches get stitches
switching sides with the law it's
supposed to be
us versus them not us versus
us harley beams with joy pudding
these are the best best impressions ever
done he's not
real i'm john
white i am the best i can remember of
joel kinnaman's performance even though
i liked him in that movie
i'm the worst real thing here i'm the
walking talking truth
or maybe i'm not and if i'm not then
this won't blow his head off
joker's thumb hovers so caught up in
trying to get the voice down i don't
even know what the dialogue was
we never cast the narrator so it's just
as needed
joker's thumb hovers over deadshot's
face on the screen
he's really he's real dude's real okay
joker you know i have had no beef with
you bring me the sword
i want the sword harley dear
please give the woman the sword harley
looks at her new friends
and shrugs the end the end that's how
the original ending goes who is
squad and then they play the that's all
folks from the old looney tunes and
that's it
what a weird page to just come out all
right let's break this down a little bit
now it's been a couple years since i've
seen suicide squad
i'm not sure is this sword referring to
katana all right that's not the biggest
takeaway from this all right
which sword the snyder cut they find
waller
she's been kidnapped by enchantress and
then this showdown
and what's really interesting here is a
joker's here he's teamed up with
enchantress and b
this creates an actual conflict where
harley
really has to choose between helping out
the suicide squad her new friends
um you know like helping save the world
too yeah or
going to puddin going to her joker i
think that would have created an actual
nice conflict i still wonder how this
would have played out in front of a
camera and edited it still seems pretty
goofy
it's just one page there's so much
missing context of flow
leading into this and all that yeah i
mean this seems more interesting than
the ending that we actually got or the
finale
showdown i like what it's suggesting
because i mean off the bat you've got
the idea that amanda waller puts this
team together and obviously
in the theatrical cut we get that whole
concern about like can you really
trust or control the enchantress and
this directly puts her
in the consequences of that which is
cool and then also going down i mean i
don't know how they would have
stylistically approached this but it
looks like they have something going
where the joker
is in some sort of hallucinatory fashion
where maybe at least briefly we could
wonder this is a real threat
a hallucination magical threat from
enchantress or something like that it
just seems like
it brings it back to the core elements i
mean it's bringing it to that but
based off of david ayers tweet from 2018
he said enchantress made a deal with him
and he was going to take harley home and
be king of garth gotham from the way
how he's talking about it here it sounds
like joker was
physically present yeah that it wasn't
some hallucination it was the sentient
joker oh no totally i mean i believe
deadshot when he says that the dude's
real but even so just the
the hints at what that could mean for
the tone of what the air cut could be
like you know yeah
gleaning it from what the script says
and uh i think this creates a
a better core conflict for all players
involved
like yes joker harley but also the
debate of like we're criminals and we're
working for the people who imprisoned us
and joker wanting to be king of gotham
the clown prince of crime i could see
how this is an upsetting
turn for him based like the fact that
these villains who he's probably worked
with in the past yeah
they even hint at a history here with
him in deadshot of like i've never had
beef with you but they at least know of
one another they could have
laid into a little bit more of an actual
debate with the characters and the
choices that they're making because
david said many times that what he was
pitching was a soulful drama
what i imagine is that what he was
pitching was what the first trailer was
you know because he got the soulful
drama we got in theaters
and it would have had made the inclusion
of joker makes sense so much more sense
instead of just feel like a perfunctory
like oh we just got to put him in
because it's you know
this this makes it feel like an
essential part for harley's journey
in this movie as opposed to plot device
or
not even really plot devices didn't do
much in the cut that came out
the other thing he put out uh just last
a couple months ago
because he's been answering a lot of
people on twitter he doesn't answer my
tweet what the hell
i asked him about the tax collector he
just wants to talk about suicide squad
where are you at here someone asked him
just out of curiosity
was he really was he really still alive
in your script uh diablo because he does
die in the
theatrical gun he says diablo survived
originally harley and deadshot hooked up
as a couple this was
changed during reshoots now funny enough
one of the things now maybe in the
original version
yeah maybe in the original script that
would work with them hook it up
in the film we got i was actually really
happy that didn't happen that there was
a hint of like sexual chemistry between
them
but they didn't actually become a couple
i preferred that choice
in the the versions that we saw of the
extended cut and theatrical cut
maybe in david ayer's original vision
yeah it works you never know what scenes
or
you know character beats were removed
and stuff like that and yeah and the
outside looking in i'm sort of like i
don't want that
you know it's so fun it's so funny to
see like how
between uh snyder cut and the air cut
how like
motives were different conflicts were
different
the scenes were just so different
everything about
the story really changed a lot
like a lot the conflicts change
sometimes you know you see these like
directors cuts and
and they're just like you know 10 to 15
minutes was cut out of the movie
bvs ultimate edition cut while that does
put that movie into like a good film
category for me elevated above the one
that was theatrical it's weird how
there's just like a few small things
they added that makes the biggest world
of difference with the
batman superman cut this is the biggest
change like there's
so much both of these versions are so
different this is like the whole second
half of the movie is probably just a
different second half of
a different movie it's not the case of a
few more added scenes would have made
this better it's like no we got it we
got completely different films
yeah in so many ways like you do get
this conflict but it seems like the
character
outcomes i really want to see this i i'm
really hoping more people
will champion for this one to come out
to and that we hear some word about this
and he's obviously playing into it like
yeah
how the hell did this leak all of a
sudden
yeah and then he goes out and confirms
it like right away
yeah yeah i mean he's probably just from
his own
like anonymous reddit account yeah
oh you know i just found this random
script page and a hard drive does
anybody know what it's
from you know like this is the head this
is
with snyder cut he kept his lip shut for
so long and then he started eventually
coming out and confirming stuff now when
people just ask
or whatever he's like yep that's what it
was yep yeah yep uh-huh
well i think that's the benefit for
david ayers yeah because we have the
snyder cut thing where that was very
public and it's like oh we have another
director coming in and then you also
have
just the fact that this has this dam is
broken now and so yeah this is
definitely
i wouldn't be surprised if this happens
soon you know because it sounds like
they shot
a ton that just got shot over yeah so
you know they could probably
you got to have finishing funds i'm sure
but i bet it will might not even cost as
much as a
bv as a justice league to you know
revamp
all right guys well do you want the air
cut what do you think of this leaked
page that david ayer himself confirmed
leave your thoughts down below you can
subscribe to the real rejects please
click that notification bell to get
notified whenever we've got a new
youtube video up hit that like button
hashtag release the air cut
last but not least
katie anne got to shout you out today my
dear because you have been posting on
your blog site through the
lookingglass.water.blog
about your experience with a lot of
movies and such and by the way i love
her blog so anytime she sends me one i
read the whole thing they're
short yet they're so eloquently put they
make for fascinating reads like her
the way she just formulates her
vocabulary
into such a poetic like language yeah
i'm like i i'll talk forever and she
could say everything i want to say but
it's brevity is the the wit of the
the this is this is this is herpent
brevity is the wit of the serpent is a
great quote
for you to get tattooed on your body i
think that's what it is she's been
covering gotham lately we're excited
that she's
been enjoying the show i know right now
you've been really working your ass off
with
you know work school trying to get a
reading coach license right now you're
doing a whole lot i'm proud of you for
still persisting during this unusual
time that we live in
but you're not giving up you're staying
strong you're staying persistent
i love the hell out of you so just keep
going at it my dear
and release the kdn cut of all of your
blogs
kdm with the fam band the john claude
van damme god damn with the jack
in the sandman with who's little clan
man
in a trans am